on passe maintenant à notre invité du
samedi 20 heures
[Musique]
car bonsoir parfois avait fait une
entrée fracassante donc sur la scène
médiatique le 17 décembre dernier vous
écoutez ce jour là la matinale de france
inter où le ministre l'agriculture bruno
le maire est invité le ministre parle de
la chute des revenus des paysans en 2009
- 34% bhl de l'organisation des marchés
des aides distribuées vous écoutez tout
ça mais intérieurement vous bouillonner
vous enragez et vous décidez sans
vraiment de raison particulière
d'appeler france inter vous dites j'ai
appelé sans trop savoir pourquoi jean
pouvait plus d'entendre ces conneries
quand on appelle on sait jamais pourquoi
en sachant très bien que des milliers de
français appellent mais des milliers de
français ont des problèmes on se dit
mais tu appelles ça sert à rien ouais
alors pierre faisait toujours travaillé
dans mon agricole mais c'est au début
des années 90 quand la grande
distribution ne veut plus achetés aux
grossistes mais aux producteurs que vous
décidez de vous lancer dans la
production de pommes et de poires à ce
moment-là vous achetez très hectares de
terrain à un mollet en provence
mais pour commencer à récolter il faudra
attendre dix ans mais disons que dans la
vie moderne ça paraît fou oui le monde
agricole a l'habitude de travailler sur
le long terme le monde agricole
travaille pour ses enfants pour ses
petits enfants ouais c'est vrai qu'on
est une race en voie de disparition
clairement alors au total vous allez
investir 600 mille euros c'est quand
même beaucoup d'argent 1 alors la
commercialisation de vos poire de vos
pommes commence en 2000 et jusqu'en 2010
tirs pendant dix ans l'exploitation des
bénéficiaires que deux ans c'est exact
en 2009 c'est particulièrement
catastrophique donc vous avez des pertes
qui s'élèvent à 120 mille euros vous
êtes obligés de vendre un bâtiment
d'exploitation exact pour récupérer ce
pognon pour pouvoir payer les annuités
les def pourquoi vous en arriver là
c'est malheureusement très simple dont
vous vendez vous 17 centimes d'euros le
kilo des poires qui déjà vous coup 40
centimes d'euro tu as déjà vous vendez à
perte je crois que c'est interdit de
vendre à perte tout à fait quand les
grandes compagnies vendent à perte
bruxelles les condamne à de très lourdes
peines pour le monde agricole en général
c'est une logique tellement banal que
plus personne n'y fait attention alors
le pire de tout c'est pas que vous
fondiez les poires 17 alors qu'elle vous
coûte 40 centimes c'est que vous voulez
retrouver ses poires à
2,80 euros voire 3 euros dans les
grandes surfaces oui c'est vrai que la
différence et ont effectivement la marge
du distributeur
elle convient à la marge du distributeur
aujourd'hui la marque d'un épicier si
vous êtes en train de nous dire en fait
c'est que ces grandes surfaces marche
comme d épicier de quartier quoi tout à
fait oui tout à fait donc ils ont plus
du tout leur vocation de grandes
surfaces c'est à dire de permettre aux
gens de payer moins cher en vost et ça
au départ on nous le fait que ça nous
ayant éliminé tous les commerces des
centres villes il se trouve seul à
proposer la marchandise est un grand
responsable m'a dit mais qu'est ce que
tu crois le consommateur qui rentre dans
mon magasin jusqu'à laquelle je peux
plus mais il va pas les faire 40
kilomètres pour je trouvais une poire à
20 centimes moins cher il est là il paye
ce pas
quand j'entends du le ministre parlait
des 34 % de perte de revenus
j'étais en colère parce qu'en fait il
est revenu et on perd 34 % ils font déjà
en amoureux oui bien sûr et donc c'est
absurde vous prêt qu'il le sait bruno le
maire ce à bordeaux le maire je vais
vous dire j'ai l'impression quand j'ai
entendu le débat tout à l'heure de vivre
sur une autre planète on se jette des
arguments ont fait croire aux gens qu'il
ya deux camps mais ya pas de camp il ya
deux camps qui veulent accéder au
pouvoir mais elle nous 50 % de la
population ne votent pas tous ces gens
qui sont sans voix et qu'on cherche même
pas à tirer alors le pire est à venir
parce que non seulement les prix sont
faibles mais ces prix vous les
connaissez pas qu'on vous vend des cires
que vous vendez vos fruits à des
organisations de producteurs des
centrales d'achat qui eux les vandales à
grand distribution est en fait ces
centrales d'achat il y en a très peu il
ya trois cent mille producteurs il ya
très peu de centrales d'achat est en
fait vous savez ce que vous avez gagné
une fois que la centrale d'achat a
vendus à la grande distribution on leur
pose les produits on n'a aucun prix tout
ce qu'on sait c'est qu'ils vont vendre
et comme ils disent au mieux vaut mieux
mais l'organisation se paye déduit ces
faits et donne le reste aux producteurs
un exemple hier je pose la question
combien on vend les golden on me dit 45
centimes quand vous enlevez les frais il
reste un centime aux producteurs en fait
vous fait cadeau de vos pommes quoi voir
l'avenir ses co-accusés 57 ans bientôt
c'est la retraite à la retraite vous
allez gagner
687 16 euros par mois c'est ce qu'on
appelle la double peine ouais c'est à
dire que tous les collègues qui
travaillent ont très souvent travaillé
quarante six ans ouais de leur vie ils
ont consacré quarante six ans embellir
la nature à produire des fruits à
produire la nourriture à toute la
population
ils font 8h à 14h travail jours les
trois quarts sans ricaine les trois cas
très peu de congés à la fin de leur vie
de travail on leur dit monsieur vous
avez enfin droit à la retraite et vous
avez droit à
697 euros 16 c'est une double peine
c'est tel mépris absolu sur mais c'est
sûr de la profession et vous avez raison
donc un paysan aujourd'hui c'est un mec
qui font la plupart du temps à perdre un
type qui a une retraite misérable après
avoir fait un boulot épuisant toute sa
vie c'est un type qui passe pour un
dingue parce que quand on le voit à la
télé ils déversent du fumier ils
déversent du lait déversé des fruits
donc les gens qui voient ça ils disent
et les cinglés c'est un type qui vit de
subventions publiques alors que c'est
pas vrai alors que vous vous en avez pas
c'est un type en plus qu'on traite de
pollueurs parce qu'on dit avec les
pesticides vous polluer les nappes
phréatiques
donc aujourd'hui non seulement vous
gagnez pas de blé vous travaillez pour
rien et en plus d'une image de mère donc
aujourd'hui un paysan c'est un damné de
la terre comme on disait de mon temps
voilà disons qu'on pourrait plutôt
résumé en exploiter à l'école oui c'est
un exploiteur c'est
alors
qu'est ce qui vous fait tenir par
rapport à ça
vous savez les paysans sa dernière à ce
qu'ils pensent à leurs enfants à leurs
petits enfants
vous voyez notre société elles ne
pensent qu'au profit immédiat
on est prêt à gagner n'importe quoi sur
n'importe qui pourvu que ce soit rapide
l'agriculteur quand ils plantent
l'agriculteur quand j'ai investi dans
des animaux l'agriculteur quand il
arrive à concevoir son exploitation il
fait un acte de création on n'est pas
des jouisseurs on a face à note à face à
nous une société de jouisseurs où tout
est permis et quand on achète des
produits en chine où on sait très bien
que l'enfant gagne 5 centimes de l'heure
on s'en fout c'est moins cher je crois
que le vrai débat c'est un vrai débat de
fond
l'agriculteur a envie de mettre l'homme
au coeur de la vie au coeur de la
société et si on est attaché à notre
métier c'est qu'il ya des risques
[Musique]
et politiques qui peuvent vous aider
tient pas comme ça non
j'ai entendu des bas tout à l'heure
j'avais envie de me tirer une balle dans
la tête ouais c'est ça serait une
solution intelligente parce qu'en fait
ils parlent d'eux il parle pas de nous
moi je dis on a des difficultés mais
j'ai conscience qu'il ya des ouvriers
qui se lève la main toute leur vie sans
jamais la moindre reconnaissance ni de
la société ni de leur société j'ai
l'impression est l'état des milliers de
chômeurs qui arrivés en fin de droits
qui sont dans notre situation
alors vous dit pierre que vous avez vous
dit pierre vous avez envie de vous tirer
une balle dans la tête excusez pas envie
de les tirer une balle dans la tête des
gens qui vous exploite comme ça sert à
rien il ya eu des jacqueries dans le
temps quand même je pense que toute
façon on est dans une crise qu'on nous
cache à force de mentir à tout le monde
on croit ses mensonges c'est ça qui
m'inquiète la chance de l'agriculteur
c'est qu'il est seul dans son champ y
réfléchit il n'a pas de de brouillage à
sa réflexion et quand on réfléchit qu'on
observe qu'on arrive à créer de l'argent
avec du vide j'observe un bénéfice de 50
milliards de la bnp cette année ouais
j'ai vraiment un sentiment de vivre au
pays des faux monnayeurs parce que
l'argent c'est le travail le travail
c'est l'outil on oublie ses ses vérités
premières et quand on fera les vrais
comptes quand on s'apercevra que le pays
est à l'arrêt et que tous ces milliards
annoncés sont du vent on verra à quel
point c'était important d'être les pieds
dans les racines donc on souffle on sait
qu'on souffre qu'on sait qu'on n'est pas
les seuls à souffrir il ya énormément de
gens qui travaillent dur qui sont
méprisés pas considérer un déni
d'existence et c'est ce déni d'existence
qu'il faut qu'on dénonce c'est pas tire
une balle dans la tête de quelqu'un de
toute façon si ça continue comme ça
l'occasion à tous sera donnée mais nous
c'est pas de dire non on a des solutions
c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'on qu'on
arrête à une solution qui est une
solution tous les cas ça serait de
rendre constructible une toute petite
partie des terrains agricoles ce qui
déjà financerait vos exploitations il
suffirait de changer un peu le plan
d'occupation des sols et puis c'est tout
un aujourd'hui il faut changer la donne
il faut qu'on accède enfin au
consommateur on a tous d une petite
partie de terrain qui est convoité par
quelqu'un qui veut mettre sa maison et
que nous ne pouvons pas le faire on
mettrait mille mètres carrés par
exploitant agricole 330 mille
exploitants agricoles 40 % de cette
somme serait donnée à la trésorerie de
l'agriculteur pour lui permettre de
respirer et 60% de cette forme somme
serait cool a créé un fonds ou les actes
les actionnaires seraient des
agriculteurs ce fonds permettrait
d'acheter des magasins à peu près 200 ou
300 simplement pour vendre au
consommateur à prix coûtant
directement auprès des consommateurs ça
nous permettrait dans tous les quartiers
difficiles l'embauché un chômeur de 55
ans qui est capable qui est compétent de
le mettre dans le magasin avec un vrai
cdi de prendre trois jeunes du quartier
sans qualification de 18 à 20 ans donc
personne ne veut de leur donner leur
chance de les employer avec des cdi
pendant des vraies qualifications et
nous ça nous permettrait enfin de
communiquer en réalité sur nos produits
sur le vrai prix que coûte notre
production ce projet il est fou mais je
pense que si on n'a pas de folie dans la
vie il vaut mieux disparaître bravo
merci de témoignages
alors elisabeth guigou il se trouve que
votre père était arboriculteurs au maroc
et qu'au moment de la décolonisation il
s'était installé en provence dans les
vergers de provence c'est une région que
vous connaissez très bien et c'est un
métier aussi que vous connaissez bien il
est venu début des années 60 il a planté
des pêches des péchés j'ai beaucoup
endetté il a eu quelques années où il a
pu rembourser ses dettes et puis après
ces produits ce que vous décrivez de
toute façon donc le verger a été il a
arraché il a refusé lui toujours d'
adhérer à un groupement de producteurs
en raison de ce que vous dit ce qu'ils
pensaient que c'était il est trop de
frais généraux tintin c'est c'est
quelque chose de terrible moi je me
souviens d'avoir vu mon père pleurer un
soir il y avait eu de la grêle
toute la production en espace d'une
heure j'ai jamais vu mon père pleurer
sauf ce jour là
voilà donc ces cinq ans avant c'est ça
alors il ya quand même un espoir est ce
que je trouve que cette proposition de
dire les agriculteurs ce groupe et ils
font leur propre magasin et ils vont
vendre directement au consommateur
moi je pense que c'est quelque chose
admire ça mon frère qui est
arboriculteur sur la même propriété avec
ma soeur aujourd'hui ils vont faire ça
les consommateurs ils vont commencer à
se rendre compte quand même que c'est
absurde on achète les pommes en chine
maintenant on achète les poires je crois
en afrique du sud et kiwis au chili la
moyenne de voyage des fruits aujourd'hui
dans le monde elle est de 2500 km le
bilan carbone c'est fou oui quand marie
ève dans ce que nous dit pierre c'est
que il nous a décrit un système qui nous
paraît à tous d'une simplicité d'un
naturel incroyable et nous dit à la fin
de sa démonstration je sais c'est fou je
pense qu'on n'y arrivera pas alors que
on en est arrivé à penser que ce que
vient de nous décrire pierre est fou
alors que les pommes qu'on achète et qui
font des milliers de kilomètres qui font
le tour du monde et qui sont en plus pas
bonne est plus cher ça ça serait naturel
alors qu on comprend bien que c'est ça
c'est la solution la solution n'est pas
très compliqué ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que on a spécialisé la france dans
l'intelligence
l'intelligence c'est 150 euros de
l'heure comment ils payent nos airbus
comment ils payent nos avions de guerre
comment il paye nos missiles dont on est
si fier avec des fruits qui sont payés
qui sont payés avec un euro de l'heure à
ceux qui travaillent parce qu'il faut
savoir que dans un fruit 80 à 85 % du
prix ne sont que de la main d'oeuvre ça
fait quoi à 40 ou 50 ans que le mépris a
commencé c'est à dire que tout ce qui
était de la terre tous les manuels
cetera c'était le dernier des cons qui
faisait ça c'était un imbécile je veux
dire on voulait pas que nos enfants
soient ouvriers on voulait pas qu'il
soit plombier que sap électricien qui
soit pas cultivateurs géo moi je vois
dans mon petit village d'aubréville je
dis à mes copains cultivateurs ils ont
eu des filles qui veulent absolument pas
faire ce métier pourquoi parce que
l'image des choses que ça nous renvoie
ne nous plaît pas et que de vous voulez
faire ainsi ap des ministres ehud ou de
plomberie ou d'ethiopie voulait être
agriculteur on vous prend pour le roi
des cons quand on voit pierre on se rend
compte que c'est bon parce qu'on a parce
que j'en connais un bon
il faut bien il faut dire que le milieu
agricole a énormément changé dans ces 40
dernières années tous les collègues
agriculteurs sont tous des techniciens
agricoles les trois quarts sont des gens
qui ont des quasiment des niveaux
d'ingénieurs ou tout du moins de cadres
1 qui ont transformé la france merci en
tous les cas de votre témoignage
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
auditive abonnez vous y mettez un peu de
bleu